[Music]
we are in the middle of graduation
season and for this year's class it's
been less pop and more circumstance
after more than two years of the
pandemic cbs news special correspondent
and nfl today host james brown recently
went back to his high school where he
was a standout basketball star he
reflected on four key lessons he learned
from his parents his teachers and his
coaches this spring jb shared those
lessons with graduates from the schools
of education and communication at
american university in washington and
now he's sharing them with us
my parents made it clear that the five
of us kids
had to understand that education and
academic excellence were the foundation
stones for success in the game of life
the first lesson i shared was explaining
my early education experience which in
fact was a tale of two types of
educators
one who in the fifth grade saw me
reading a book titled so you want to be
a doctor
without hesitation she told me that kids
like me
don't do well in math and science and i
should choose another profession
crushing words never to be forgotten
you know words are powerful potentially
life-altering especially at a young age
and coming from an authority figure
rejection is a powerful weapon against
one's self-worth and those seeds planted
in the soil of unbelief can produce a
harvest of failure
in fact i did struggle academically
until the seventh grade when thankfully
both my homeroom teacher and french
teacher encouraged me by making it clear
that i did have gifts and talents and
they would help me
and those gifts would be developed with
good old-fashioned hard work
that was right in line with what my
brothers sister and i always heard from
our parents who were high school
graduates with
phds in drive and determination
the lesson here is that the best
educators use words that inspire
edify and exhort
high expectations from educators
do yield fruit
lesson two i addressed a concern that
the future journalists had about how
they would fit in this rapidly changing
media environment and i emphasized
excellence always stands out
to have an insatiable appetite for
learning
to pursue a variety of assignments and
to be inquisitive
evans i did a gymnastics event with
olympic gold medalist mary lou retton
and i asked her why the men
didn't do routines on the balance beam
like i saw the women doing
well she uh sheepishly
didn't answer the question
assuming i would figure it out pretty
quickly
and um
i did learn to ask better questions
after that
the third major lesson was to establish
the importance of having an excellent
foundation how are you doing so far sir
how are you american military hero
general norman schwarzkopf in a speech
to corporate titans stressed that in his
research of why many leaders failed
despite their impressive skill sets was
due to their lack of virtues
specifically character and integrity
roosevelt cheered as president of the
united states that brought to mind the
quote by former american president
theodore roosevelt
who said quote to educate in mind and
not in morals is to educate a menace to
society
the fourth and final lesson
it's not just about winning it's the way
you win
something i learned here at dematha
catholic high school from my coach
morgan wooten he finished an
incomparable 46-year career with the
winningest record in the country and
became the first high school coach to be
inducted into the naismith basketball
hall of fame
and just like pro football hall of fame
coach tony dungy
and the legendary college football hall
of fame coach eddie robinson the common
thread between these uncommon leaders is
that they never used profanity with
their players
they all ascribed to the belief that the
most effective four-letter word you can
use and model to ensure success in any
profession
is l l-o-v-e
[Music]
love
because love is not boastful or proud or
rude
it never gives up it never loses faith
because love
is more
durable and it will always last and now
i encourage you go out and knock them
alive god bless you
[Applause]
jb's parents drive and focus on
education and academic excellence proved
to be the foundation for his success he
was elected president of his high school
class and became the first
college-educated member of his family
graduating from harvard university well
just recently jb was honored with the
induction into the sports broadcasting
hall of fame
he is quite a role model he's amazing
he's an amazing person he's amazing
broadcaster i tells a great story i just
why i i stay glued to the screen when i
see him come on and he is as good a man
off camera as he is on camera he is the
best
colleague you could ever have one of my
favorite people